despite mostly taking place and the far
far off reaches of outer space thor
ragnarok hits very close to home for
many marvel fans like most films on the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's full of
some pretty deep cuts into Marvel's
comic pages here are a few Easter eggs
you'll find in Ragnarok and of course
there are Hulk size spoilers ahead throg
the first and the most obvious reference
to Marvel Comics strange history is when
it's revealed that loki once turned to
Thor into a frog but really happened for
a couple of issues at least during one
of Loki's many attempts to overthrow
Asgard it all starts in Thor issue 364
and whines it's strange way through Thor
frog of thunder meeting a bunch of rats
escaping death by alligator playing a
game of Frogger across a road and having
a run-in with a psychic flute playing
more Locke in the sewers while a
completely different frog would
eventually take up the mantle after Thor
reverted back to his honky Asgardian
form it's such a weird part of Thor
history but it may just be one of his
most iconic tales by beast and company
frog isn't even the most unexpected
character to show up in MCU continuity
over the course of Ragnarok sure weirdos
like Howard the Duck and Cosmo the space
dog a strange but it rarely gets more
bizarre than the four characters whose
enormous busts are positioned around the
Grand Master's tower all of whom were
presumably champions at one point
first there's by beast a robot who bares
a pair of impossibly stucked faces and
who made his first appearance in The
Incredible Hulk issue 169 you'll also
find a bust of Ares Marvel's very own
God of War who appeared in Thor 129 and
another character whose power seems far
too enormous to comfortably slip into a
Marvel film third there's beta ray Bell
a deer-like alien with the same powers
of store and a powerful ally to Asgard
who first appeared in Thor issue 337
finally there's Man Thing a magical
scientist turned swamp monster who is
definitely from Earth and the only one
among these champions to not have a
special connection to Hulk or Thor as
the garbage dump of the universe Sekar
really sees some diversity but let's
head back to that crazy space deer for a
second
exiled Asgardians by the end of Ragnarok
we have a bunch of homeless as Guardians
floating around in a spaceship which is
a scene that might seem a little
familiar to truth orphans way back in
Thor issue 337 a korbinite alien named
beta ray bill is in a similar situation
when Thor finds him floating around on a
spaceship called Scuttlebutt's which
itself bears some resemblance to the
Asgardians escape vehicle in Ragnarok
he too is a champion of his people and
in search of a new home after Surtur
destroyed their planet
if Bill's giant burst on circars display
of deceased champions as any indication
his story didn't end nearly as
positively as it did in the comics
contest of Champions
once on Sekar and enslaved by the
Grandmaster Thor gets to run down on the
whole gladiatorial arena thing courtesy
of a willy wonka style trip through a
horror tunnel and an explanation from
the Grandmaster himself who refers to
his staged fights as a contest of
Champions not coincidentally contest of
Champions is the exact title of a 1982
Marvel miniseries starring the
Grandmaster who challenges death to add
or using Marvel's best and brightest as
their champions their heroes included
Iron Man she-hulk and Arabian night they
weren't all winners
scrapper 142 while Thor's original lady
captor isn't even given a formal name
aside from scrapper 142 she's generally
referred to as a foul curry there's some
precedent for both names even if neither
a totally correct marvel's Valkyrie or
rather an imposter version of her
created by The Enchantress plays a major
role in a one-shot tale in the
Incredible Hulk issue 142 the Valkyrie
in Ragnarok isn't the one and only
Valkyrie and the number 142 is a pretty
big hint that she's just borrowing the
name for now so where's the real
Valkyrie it's possible that we see
marvel's original heroine being spared
during scrapper 142 s flashback battle
with hella given that the word Valkyrie
also applies to a whole regiment of
warrior women it's safe to assume that
the name probably gets passed around a
lot Infinity Gauntlet one of the most
confounding things in MCU mythology is
the presence of the Infinity Gauntlet
while it's become the locus of absolute
power over the course of marvel's films
it made its first appear
the original Thor as a treasure stored
safely in Asgard while it was mostly a
throwaway reference to some intense
cosmic Marvel stuff it led many
eagle-eyed Marvel fans to wonder why
there was more than one Infinity
Gauntlet floating around the MCU since a
nose clearly had one also the entire
scenario is retconned in one line when
hella calls a gauntlet and Asgard out as
a fake problem solved right but why did
owning keep a dummy glove in his
basement
was it a decoy did he think it was real
or did he just pick it up at Comic Con
and thought that have really tied the
room together the world will never know
King Kirby old-school comic geeks could
tell from ragnaroks early trailers that
the film will be drawing very heavily
from the art style of Jack Kirby one of
Marvel's original architects and the
original artists of Thor a vast majority
of the costume designs a scene on Sekar
were based on Kirby's drawings of
Celestials and other strange alien gods
but one thing was pulled directly from
Kirby's comic pages the enormous
drawings on the walls of the Grand
Master's viewing chambers the guy's got
amazing taste
and of course nobody missed thought
original creator Stan Lee a sacar shaky
handed barber right and speaking of
Marvel's many creators
there's also cousin Carlo played by
Steven Oliver he may be a bit of a
throwaway character and he's most
definitely melted all over the
grandmasters floor but he was named
after artists Carlo pug a lion who
illustrated parts of Marvel's Planet
Hulk storyline which served as the
inspiration for much of Ragnarok fake
Thor in what might be one of the most
unexpected cameos and all of the MCU
we're treated to Matt Damon and Sam
Neill Damon and Neil are playing the
parts of Loki and Odin respectively in
Loki Odin's very own self-aggrandizing
play the actor playing fake Thor is a
little harder to pin down because it
looks a lot like Chris Hemsworth the
reason for that is that is played by
another Hemsworth Chris's brother Luke
although it's brief it's a pretty
cleverly cast hands-only Hemsworth
easter egg
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team
[Music]